[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
yeah Mark you've been around the block
I'm sure you've had met your fair share
of uh ladies that like to you know
participate in different new and fun
kinky things have you ever
um participated in horseplay
I'm Miss Anne with the LA Pony and
critter Critter club by
Fatima role play enthusiasts it's
actually something very deep to it
who would you how would you feel
yeah that's the look you're supposed to
have
with all of this stuff I I you know
because I
I just I just you know I I like to I
just like to come as hard as possible so
yeah you know like what's on the screen
this is a horrible or hilarious that uh
that you sent me oh
um and we still haven't gone through my
new tick tocks BTS so do you uh if we
did right yeah the new ones yeah yes oh
sorry I forgot yeah um yeah so if you
think you might you watch this and you
tell us whether it's horrible or
hilarious okay okay
thank you
oh
um
I'm happy he fell out
I had to fall out I think so yeah yeah I
mean that that didn't sound good at all
it was guttural like like it took an
extra second for him to realize how much
pain he was in you know what I mean it
sucks did he fall on it he got his wind
knocked out for sure yeah he did wait
can we hear it again I like the sound
are you kidding it sounds like his spine
went into his [__] he's he's at least
20 feet up right yeah he's about 30.
he's just leaning out oh then he falls
he sounds like a Florida State fan
yeah
did he land on a thorn bush like how
humiliated
I mean how many lips did he do it but at
least it broke it's his fault and by the
way I don't think the pilots no they're
just like yeah they're gone just keep
going yeah
they're just like
I don't know
now all I hear is a seminar it's like
really drunk
what's gonna happen so I'll uh let's see
oh yeah let it out hurry up oh I don't
know where's the poop now oh giddy up
ah don't bite my ass okay let out I'm
ready
um do you see my [__] face I did see
and that's exactly why we played oh my
God and then I I gen I genuinely am like
oh this is so funny he's gonna [__] his
pants no no no and she's like hurry up
no yes right in your mouth no no no guys
yeah no yeah right in their mouth what
would you do if your wife started this
with you if wanted me to fart in her
mouth that's it seriously that is it do
it again yeah
art in your mouth yeah what's the
problem I don't see the big there's
no problem
the phone is ringing yeah an old timey
phone what kind of chick what percentage
of chicks you think are are into this
yeah
and by the way my heart is open to this
man okay what's up strong Church Chris
here you know they always say that
preacher jokes are the worst so we
thought we'd put that to the test this
is the preacher joke challenge here we
go how do we know that cars are in the
New Testament
because Jesus was a car painter carpet
can you pause it please yeah yeah
that's one of the worst jokes I've ever
heard
tell us why yeah yeah it's
it's like forcing
okay let's see seriously if you need to
be doing this
what are you doing oh what are you doing
hello what are you doing go away lady
what are you doing there's people
there's little kids around here what are
you doing filming them seriously
so he's got a missing leg is he putting
the prosthetic limb up his ass he sure
is Tom holy cow is he really
he's trying to
by the way he doesn't even want to watch
himself do it is that what the towel is
for he covers his face or he knew
somebody was he's like look this is
probably gonna be a thing Instagram
worthy someone's gonna come by I want to
take something I respect it because I've
had those middle middle of the day urges
where you're like I just gotta do it now
you know yeah but outside under the
freeway side on the side of the road I
take my leg off shouldn't there be more
concern in her voice
by the way yeah if you had limbs to
remove God damn dude no I'm concerned
why there's not more concern in her
voice she just sounds like she just what
are you doing saw somebody like push her
kid off the slide what are you doing
with that
um the blur it doesn't go there I wish
it wasn't there is there a way to
digitally remove it uh I don't have the
unblurred version on this computer is um
where what site was this on
uh I forget I think someone just emailed
it to us and might have just this is oh
I could actually this is horrifying yeah
no this has to be I've seen so much [__]
on this show this is hands down the most
horrifying thing I've ever take us
through your thoughts no thanks yeah
what part of it do you think this was a
dare this reminds me of living in San
Francisco in the 90s when you'd be
walking down the street and you would
just see like guys butt [__] or like
just outside of I swear it was wild it
was in the 90s it was wild guys were
just [__] each other this guy's going
what's up to butt [__] yeah just on
every corner but you would see this in
San Francisco I feel like expect that
this guy is trying to be modest with the
covering the face I don't know if it's
is it modesty yeah I mean nobody's he's
like I don't want to be I don't want to
maybe there's a part two and he's gonna
reveal his face hey he takes it off or
it's like if you want me to stop you're
gonna have to grab this towel off my
face he's not even hard are you think
that he would probably got no eyes how
do you know it's not hard how do you
know he's not high because I could tell
bestest promo ever if you love comedy
want to support up-and-coming comedians
we're featuring a new one on our
Instagram every single day go follow
Lincoln bio right now we'll send you
some free stickers when you do bye hit
that make sure the volume is on poor guy
so great
did you know growing up hey I might be a
stand-up comedian despite what they are
on charge today
young I I was molested by an uncle and
that gave me superpowers to be funny
because he was funny so it's kind of
like a Spider-Man origin so
all right you can close it the sound is
the audio's not good but if you if you
had trouble hearing it they go did you
always know you're gonna be funny he
goes no but when I was a kid I was
molested by an uncle and he was funny so
it gave me super powers like a
Spider-Man origin score and then they go
okay all right I don't know where to go
with that they always say that I don't
know where to go with that I'm not a
human anymore how would you feel about a
lady you're on a date yeah and I think
it's important to highlight that she's
hot so you're like this she's smoking
hot okay and then she's like oh you know
I'm kind of kinky and you're like great
me too and then she's like hey so you're
gonna be the master I'm gonna I'm gonna
be you had uh it was best confirmation
like if you're a rubber Pony you look
like a rubber
here she's like this right you know so
and she's like Galloping if it possibly
ended in you coming super hard yeah I
don't think it does with this stuff
though no I think that the thing is more
about the the tension of it right this
is the opposite of coming because look
at all this gear they have on it's an
elaborate thing it goes on for hours
when she she gets such a thrill from you
participating in this part of it yeah
but the payoff for her is like I'm gonna
suck your balls through your ass when
we're done with this wow yeah
watching
I've been watching uh this actually hi
I'm Peyton Lafferty and I'm a ball hog
let's go to the next I appreciate your
rage at this time me too why did Noah
have to punish and discipline the
chickens on the ark hold on hold it hold
it
why did Noah have to punish and
discipline I feel like discipline is a
clue all right the chickens on the ark
because they were clucking around mmm I
don't think you can do that yeah because
that sounds like [__] I know you're
right you can't be that
um
chickens I mean it's gonna be something
about yeah
a bunch of a bunch of something with
eggs right they were to get to the other
side no discipline they were excited
they were too excited to be on me
eggs
look at him laughing here's the best
part this nerd is like a language
it's not terrible that one's at least
it's not terrible but that last right
here is so big but I do yes that's
perfect the lap was too big and the
guy's delivery was not very good it was
very dead pan but this what's going on
here just one more little dip into the
repeat preaching pool is is like what
are we saying about a faith for grown
intellectual interesting people when the
jokes that we can appreciate are baby
jokes right you know what I mean like we
don't understand have you read the Bible
have you read the book of Job have you
seen the complexity and the sex and the
violence and the doubt and the shame and
the fear in that book and that people
are actually drawn to Jesus do you know
Jesus drew a crowd it's like [__]
hanging out with Jim Carrey like if you
went people came and listened to him
it's not because he was saying they had
foul [__] language do you understand
you think you can draw an impromptu
crowd back in the day when like 15 feet
over someone's like just killing a goat
for fun like look at
like you had medieval [__] to compete
with people wanted to listen to Jesus
and it's become like how many lollipops
before a Jew goes to hell like how the
[__] I gotta show you this so this was
this is where I'm watching yeah yeah
yeah so there's a this this uh these
twins were on uh in Australia on
Australian TV I'm a twin I should know
yeah
they're mixed race twins let's forget
them but I'm not sure Listen to I've
read science you gotta listen to the uh
I've read signs the anchor like just
clearly listen to what they say go ahead
one of the sisters is obviously black
rabba is white the alma twins come from
a mixed race family in the UK Maria has
taken after her half Jamaican mum with
dark skin and brown eyes and curly dark
hair but Lucy got her dad's fair skin
good on it along with straight Red Room
whoa
look at the guy he's the guy who said
the way Mike Myers snapped his head when
Kanye said George Bush doesn't care
about black people he was like wait a
second this is live right now I'm stuck
with that
ah you got the good stuff by the way I'm
very observant I watched down here that
the it went from 24 degrees to 25
degrees it's almost the same temperature
in this goddamn studio right now I know
what's going on here what is this guy no
oh yeah he's got a uh what are we eating
what are we eating
what are we eating for lunch we can
figure you're the one that's pregnant
you're eating for two
no let's figure this out now all right
no you're not good
so what is what is uh is this like a
healing thing he does yeah yeah this guy
is starting like some sort of cult or
something like some sort of Buddhist ROM
dog ramdon type guy but uh
Ramadan
ramdas he's a guru he's spiritual leader
God bless him okay
what is that he's in here why I first
met Kelly in the year 2000 or 99 and
after a few months me and Kelly and
someone else a third friend and then
Kelly after a few months he discovered
it himself in the bathroom because we
were like taking the same techniques he
was doing so he wanted to you know push
it to the next level raise the bar so he
found a way to drink nose in the
bathroom I get it now you showed me
first
he's snorting urine oh it's urine yeah
oh so it's like a urine I know there's
like a whole urine therapy it's the best
you can bathe in it there's people that
give themselves yes
yeah rain Florence yeah here's the this
is real people have asked that this is
totally real I love this this is like
she doesn't know I'm there
[Music]
wait that it's real
you don't know it's not anymore
ever yeah yeah
when you guys play these clips do the
people in the clips ever
acknowledge sometimes podcast
no sometimes
do they ever reach yeah like either
that's not funny or stop doing it I love
it uh sometimes like I always love the
people who you're like
um look at this [__] [__] show
they're like can I come on and you're
like no
um and then the people here like I wish
we could figure out who this is you
never never hear
[Music]